The general good experience. That's the thing, right? It's like,
are you responsible for the people who also comment on your post?
And th this is,
this is where we're getting to this like Vox thing that's happening with Steven
Crowder right now. Right? Are you responsible for the reaction to what you post?
Because if you look at what Steven Crowder said to that, if we don't,
people don't know the story.
Steven Crowder got into it with this guy who is a writer for Vox who,
uh, is, he's gay. His Twitter handle is gay wank.
Maza yeah. So it's not that he's hiding that he's gay.
He talks about it all the time. He's kind of a feminine.
And Steven Crowder mock that and he mock that in these videos where he was
criticizing Carlos.
His position on Antifa is specifically what I saw.
And in, in doing that, he called him, uh,
this queer Mexican, this like, and he's doing it in a ribbing way.
He's doing it in a joking way.
And then Carlos Mazda posts all these horrible tweets that came his way.
And apparently he got docs so people got his phone.
And they were saying debates.
Steven Crowder was getting all these text messages in and all this, uh,
hateful stuff that was coming his way. So the question is,
who is responsible for that hateful stuff?
If Steven Crowder calls him queer is what is queer?
Okay, is LBGTQ, what do we do there?
What do we do if the cue is an Izzy is,
is it okay to call someone gay who identifies as gay?
If he calls him the gay little Mexican? Is that, is that right?
Bad? Like what is, how bad is that? Like what is that like? I'm saying,
but so do you feel what I'm saying here? It's like,
do I know where you're getting at? Let's zoom out a little bit and then we'll,
we'll get into this. Okay. Man, where do you even start with this?
Because there's a lot to unpack here, right?
If we will analyze the specifics in a second maybe,
but first if you look at the policy, the terms of service of YouTube,
there's a verge article from yesterday before, a few days ago,
earlier this week before YouTube had made the decision to demonetize Steven
Crowder.
Well they made the decision to not act and just say that it didn't violate the
terms of services and then today as I got in here,
Jamie informed me that they made a decision to Monde.
That's right. So in the article where they made the decision not to act,
they actually put what YouTube terms of service are with regard to bullying and
harassment. My reading of it and we could go through them.
If we could pull them up, we could go through it line by line if we wanted.
My reading was that the, that definitely did break the terms and conditions.
That was my view as I looked at what it was that was done by Steven Crowder and
what the terms of service are. Just matching it up,
not looking at the comments from either poses specifically.
It was specifically targeting an individual.
On the basis of sexual orientation,
but he wasn't targeting them on the basis of it.
He was mentioning that with his bad ideas,
he was targeting his bad ideas in regards to Antifa a lot of that he was
dismissing Antifa. But if you look at Crowder's video, uh,
and I can't believe I spent so much time doing this,
but it's not like a whole hour on this two days ago. Yeah. Um,
he was talking about how Carlos just dismisses Antifa as being not that big a
deal and that there's bias in the media whenever there's anything negative that
happens. But if you look at the overall picture,
and then Crowder goes on to talk about all the assaults,
all the murders that there was sexual assaults, there was rapes,
there was all these things that happen with Antifa.
He was talking about all these different people that got maced in the face.
All of these people that got hurt and, and he's highlighting all,
like this is not something to easily dismiss. Sure.
And that the FBI had labeled Antifa a terrorist organization. So,
so far it's just politics. It's just what, what does he think?
What do I think so far it's just that part of it. And along the way he's like,
yeah, but the queer little Latino says this. Yeah. And when he does that,
that's where it's like, okay, what is he doing? Is he ma?
He's kind of mocking him. Right. And he's mocking him by saying he's queer,
but he says he's queer or he says he's gay. Yeah. But that's like saying,
I mean listen, just because theN word is in rap songs,
it doesn't mean that any that that defined to go and write,
but the N word is not in like,
it's not like then the LBGT N, you know what I'm saying?
It's not like a part of their, their organ. It's,
I think the principle though is you're suggesting that because a certain word is
sometimes used self referentially by members of a group that any use of it from
the outside is by definition not problematic.
And I'm just saying it's more complicated and you've got certainly more
complicated. You do have to look at specifics. I'm G I'm going from memory,
but wasn't Steven Crowder also wearing a shirt that said fags with the a with an
astrophysics wink, wink, nudge nudge.
It said socialism is for figs and Halley's calling a gay gay is a fig instead of
a, an I as he's calling a gay guy acquitted in Mexico. Yes. Yeah.
I mean in total it's not crazy. So, but no, there's,
there's certainly an argument that, well,
I don't necessarily think the tee shirt is for Carlos Mesa.
I think that's a T shirt that he just has, cause he thinks it's funny.
And because Che Guevara who is on the shirt is,
that is one of the weirdest things that people worship. That guy,
he was a horrific human being. A mass murderer, a terrible sociopath,
a psychopath. And because he looks good and calls in the Cuban revolution,
elders with the Baret on, you know, he's,
he became for a long time. I mean, it's kind of died off,
but he became like the Wolk poster boy. I'm from Argentina. I, I know.
Uh, I, we born there. Yeah, no kidding. Yeah, sure. So, I mean, listen,
here's all my country, bro. I'm, I made it. Um, so listen,
I think that I, I've, I do appreciate what you're saying and I agree with you
to a certain extent. I believe that when YouTube yesterday said,
we looked at the content in total and we don't think it violates our terms and
conditions. I disagreed with them.
I thought it very clearly violated their terms and conditions.
Where I am thinking about it now is the application of those terms and
conditions violations. Because a similar thing happened with Alex Jones as well,
which was there's lots of way smaller players that are violating these same
terms and conditions, but nobody knows about them.
YouTube doesn't know about them,
they don't get any attention because they have no audience.
So I think there's the question of the application of these terms and
conditions,
conditions in a way that's sort of fair and is not ultimately going by the
public blow back or reaction to situations because that that's how ad pocalypse
1.0 [inaudible] happened again,
I think it was a Coke ad appeared on an obviously racist video on a channel with
like 800 or a thousand subscribers. The wall street journal, I think it was,
did an article saying,
look at these screenshots of these advertisers on these crazy racist videos that
led to blow back because YouTube didn't want to lose money and ultimately that's
what this is about.
I know that there are people who say YouTube has an inherently left wing bias.
Others say YouTube has a of right-wing by whatever YouTube's bias is towards
corporatism and profit. Yes.
That's fundamentally what it is and as a company they have a left wing bias.
I don't know that in what sense?
Well in the sense that the woman who's the CEO of YouTube was talked about it
pretty openly, like the fact that she doesn't,
what was it that she had gotten into? What did she, Oh, well,
first of all was the, the James Demore thing. You know,
she was talking about the Google memo and she was talking about how it was, uh,
incredibly damaging, damaging, uh,
damaging stereotypes against women, which it just wasn't,
this is not accurate.
Is home Depot a right wing company because the CEO supports Trump?
[inaudible]
that's a good question. Um, I'm basing it on that.
They're a part of Facebook and Facebook is pretty clearly left wing part of
Facebook. Google, Oh, sorry. Google. They're part of Google. I meant Google.
Okay. Google is a, a very,
very left wing group and it's all Silicon Valley,
which is almost entirely left wing biased.
So I think we have to distinguish between the personal political biases of
Silicon Valley entrepreneurs and the broader place that Google has in the sort
of corporate sphere.
Google is part of the group of huge multinational corporations that lobbies for
particular tax policy to avoid paying taxes legally.
That is not a particularly left wing thing to do. Uh, Google is, um,
part of the large tech companies that in order to avoid serious regulation of
their businesses have come up with this idea of regulating themselves. Okay.
Which I know is a topic self-regulation that's come up before on your program in
a variety of ways. So those are not left wing things.
And if you want to make the case that as a company,
it has a left wing politic in the outward facing world,
you have to have something more than just a lot of their engineers live in Palo
Alto and are hipsters who go to coffee shops. You think? I think that in the,
in terms of the place that it occupies within the economic system we have,
they are not very different from all of the large corporations that are pushing
against regulation, pushing for ways to avoid taxes, period.
So in terms of economic decisions, yeah. I mean, listen, if,
if we want to talk about how the personal politics of the employees translate to
policy, we can do that,
but we need to be able to make some specific claims about how, how it does,
what I'm saying is we know the way in which the structure that Google is a part
of leads to it advocating for things that are center, right.
Corporatist, capitalist, the status quo of tax shelters,
havens and not paying taxes, regulating ourselves, et cetera, et cetera. Well,
that's what's interesting about this Crowder thing is they're ultimately,
the decision was to allow him to have his freedom to post videos on there.
But the punitive aspect of it is they're gonna reduce his ability or eliminated
his ability to make money from it. Well, I should say reduce, right?
Because he could, couldn't he put videos, put ads up in his video?
Yeah, I mean, you can add. So like we, one, one thing that I do is we,
uh,
we kind of split off the ad sales from my show into an ad agency and we're doing
ad sales, not just for my show but for other shows as well.
And those include ad placements that are not like the pre-roll ads on YouTube.
It's, the host is actually talking about a product or whatever. Right.
It's a re, you know, alive read sort of thing. Unbox therapy does a lot of that.
Hm. Yeah. That's where I first saw those who does some pretty extensive ones.
Okay. So of course you can do that. I mean, yeah, the,
there's nothing he can do that,
but he can't just collect revenue like I assume he's been doing before.
He has a significant number of followers. I think his, uh,
his YouTube subscribers are more than three and a half million. So it's,
it's very high. Yeah.
More than me and Dave just eliminated his income. Right.
Comes out of YouTube. And this was their decision based on his,
his way of talking about Carlos Mesa.
That's, that's what happened. Yeah. I mean, so what, what are the concerns?
To me it's not that he didn't violate terms and conditions. Like I said,
I think he pretty clearly did the concerns to me are, um,
is YouTube only going to even look into these circumstances or instances when
there is a public outcry? The answer is probably yes.
Because why would they look into stuff nobody's paying attention to.
It's not a good change.
Their decision based on public outcry based on Carlos Mays's reaction to the
initial decision. I happen to think their initial decision was the wrong one.
But I have a sort of broader concern here,
which is about the fairness of the application and also the distinguishing
between a content that is promoting whatever falls under any of our definitions
of hateful or whatever content and those who are fighting against it.
So is it because he mentioned his sexual orientation and that he called him a
list B little queer or whatever. You call them, more queer Mexican.
And if he just called him a fucking idiot and he received the exact same amount
of hate, would you still think that that was a good move?
No. I mean,
I think that it would not fall under what they are now claiming as the
justification for the demonetization. It would be different.
It would have the same result.
The only difference would be they wouldn't be attacking his sexual orientation
specifically because of crowd. That's the only difference.
It's policing speech, you know? It really is. Here's
so, so who gets to decide if not the private businesses,
what their rules are. That's where the real question comes up. Right?
Tulsi Gabbert believes that it's a first amendment issue and she believes that
everyone should have the freedom of expression.
And then as long as you're not doing anything illegal,
you're not putting anyone in danger by giving up their address or doxing them or
something along those lines or making overt physical threats that you should be
allowed to do that because that's what the freedom of speech is all about.
And freedom of speech when you eliminate social media in this country is your,
your, your freedom is basically, yes. Yelling, yelling out in public.
I mean you're, you're, we're in this weird place. It's a, what's it called, sir,
as a culture,
it's unprecedented really in terms of the waters we're navigating right now.
There's a couple of different things to F. so I like the principal,
like my principal is,
we do almost no moderation on any of our platforms that my program is on.
My only thing that I tell my team is if you see something that really seems to
be illegal, it's calling for violence, it, whatever the these are,
we have a very, very high bar before we will remove anything. And quite frankly,
we're just too busy.
What did, what do you mean by that? I'm just, I'm confused.
Like who's not your videos? Who's video?
Yeah. And so if we find out that on our videos,
someone is posting endless comments [inaudible] in the comments.
Second comments. My personal view is if it's not illegal, I just,
just let it all be there and yeah, that's my personal view.
And that's a great principle to have.
Well we don't touch them. We leave them alone even though we get accused of it.
But the, the question is YouTube at one point in time
had thrown out there that they were going to make people responsible for the
things that were in their comments. I vaguely remember that.
But it didn't ultimately happen backed out of it very quickly when they realized
that places like yours,
which like your average video gets how many thousands of comments a lot and many
of them antisemitic. And how would you, yeah.
And how would you even be able to look at all those?
I mean you would have to be 24,
seven monitoring 'em cause you've also got people that are watching your videos
from overseas at all times in the night. Yup.
So I think that the principle of only only illegal content will be removed is
great. That's a PR. That's my personal principle. However,
I think that there is no serious case to be made that a private company,
uh, can't say these are our terms of service. And if you want to,
I mean it's sort of almost a conservative principle, right?
The idea that unless illegal things are going on,
we are not going to tell a business how it is that it should be run.
And that's where I think a lot of right-wingers start to stumble on this issue
because they're calling for a very invasive form of government regulation.
They're calling for the government to step in and even break up these
organizations because they've gotten too large.
But you're hearing that from the left as well. Yeah.
Well I think there's a diff,
there's a difference though between Elizabeth Warren saying we should separate
the social platform Facebook from the ad sales revenue generating piece of it.
That's one thing that falls under antitrust.
That's different than saying the government should come in and it should tell
anybody who runs a social network that you can't even,
you can't do anything unless the content is illegal because there are financial
considerations, right? I mean there's lots of content that would not be illegal,
but it would make a platform, a video platform like YouTube,
not financially viable because advertisers would see it and they'd say, Oh,
we're not going near that. Right,
so I have a very hard time taking what is a very authoritarian perspective that
the government should come in and say,
this is how social networks should be run. Now if you want to change the law,
here's the way it could be done.
If you want to change the law and argue that these platforms have gotten so big
that they represent more of a town square, so to speak,
then okay, maybe you could pass a law that changes how they would be regulated,
but that's typically the type of stuff the Rite is against because it is more
regulation. It is more regulation,
but it's regulation to keep a private company from regulating against free
speech. Do you see what I'm saying? It's, it's a sneaky kind of regulation.
It's a regulation that's enforcing the first amendment and the people's ability
to freely express themselves.
If we're admitting or if we're agreeing that we are entering into this new
world. Yes. Where this is I,
that's my position is that it is a town square and I feel like everybody should
be able to communicate.
The really unfortunate unsavory aspect of it is when someone gets harassed like
Carlos Mesa was because of this,
where people are sending him all these homophobic tweets and all the,
and he's getting text messages and all this shit that's,
that's the unsavory and unfortunate aspect of it. And how do you stop that?
I don't know how you stop it. I don't know exactly how you stop it,
but I think it would be useful.
I mean one thing is when does a platform get big enough in your mind that it
would qualify for this? Like town square designation? Well for sure YouTube.
Let's talk about that one because that's the one we're on.
I mean fucking God damn it. It's huge. It's gigantic.
So are there other types of businesses through which communication happens that
you think should be regulated in the same way? That's not really clear.
So I'll give an example. Okay.
If you start regularly sending people via ups,
uh,
similar things to some of the content that exists on YouTube and ups says we're
getting reports that you're sending people harassing stuff.
We don't want you as a customer here anymore. Here's a question though,
isn't there a difference between someone sending something to a physical address
and someone sending something?
Let's say to you when your social media apps are on the third page of your phone
and you have to swipe all the way over to get them and open it up and you have
to read them. If you want to find them,
well you don't necessarily have to read them.
There's a difference in a practical sense,
but I guess the question is would we want the government,
would you similarly want the government to enforce for telephone companies?
If you are harassment, getting harassing texts and you report it and report it,
that's a different thing I think.
I think what is coming to your phone and the phone is ringing.
I think that's a another step. It's another step towards invasive.
It's a big gray area. Yes. Is the phone ringing? Is it a phone call?
Is it a text? Is it a WhatsApp message? You have to read that text, right? Yeah,
no, I feel you. I guess the question where I hesitate,
and again I'm speaking as someone from the left who believes regulation of
businesses is an important thing.
I would want to be really sure about how it exactly it is that the government
would step in and mandate essentially that their view has to be listened to over
the terms of service that a private company would wish to have. Yes.
I feel like when you give people a gun,
they start looking for targets and that that is a very common thing.
If you give people the ability to censor and give people the ability to sensor
based on their political ideology or based on what they feel is offensive,
where other people don't, it's a slippery slope and I think that that can,
that can lead to all sorts. Look that woman,
what is her name again? The one who tried to get Amy Siskind.
Imagine her being in charge of a social media platform.
She tried to get you fired from Boston college for something that was incredibly
polite. Right. That is what I'm talking about. Is that very action,
that very same type of thinking that she tried to impose on you?
That's what I'm worried about.
Well they're worried about people that are really strictly trying to promote
their ideologies and what they think is okay and
not okay and it's very slippery cause there's a lot of weird people out there
that believe a lot of weird things and want other people to conform to those
weird things.
And we sort of have to decide like that's why I'm bringing up this Crowder
thing. Like do I think that what he said was good? No,
it's not nice to call someone a little less be queer. It's not nice.
It's kind of mean, you know?
And especially when that guy wasn't even engaging with him.
But he's making fun of him. He's a comedy show. He's mocking them.
So the question becomes like, when,
when is that mocking considered homophobic and when is it just ribbing? Right.
And that's his position. His position is that it's just ribbing.
This is the problem with a discussion that is only about the principles.
So like a lot of our conversation for the last 15 minutes has been what is our
principle about what types of business regulation is okay for the government to
do and is not okay. Or when we talk about free speech,
what should it do?
We have a principle of anything short of illegal content versus something that
is more strict. The reality is that it's, there is more gray area
trying to sort of regulate the way people communicate with each other.
So it's not, it's like if someone said that to someone in a bar,
a cop would not arrest them. Like yeah, you listen to a little queer, you know,
that would be like, Oh that guy's an asshole.
But the bar would be perfectly within their legal right to say we don't,
we don't want you in here. You're making our customers uncomfortable.
And nobody would say that. It would be against the law for the bar to say,
you got to go.
And that's a good point. If they were doing it to their face,
but what if he was in a corner talking about this guy that wasn't there and he
was saying, yeah,
so he's talking about Antifa this list be a little Mexican queer.
If you came along and decided to kick the guy out of the bar, then
it would, I mean, listen at some bars,
if you go into the corner and you yell about a lispy and Mexican queer,
they're going to ask you to leave and it still would not be illegal and the bar
would still not be doing anything. Right.
But that's a bar, right?
That's a private business where people are physically there. Yes.
Isn't there a difference between that and something like YouTube,
which again falls more in line with like a town square?
Maybe that's what we need to revisit that because so much human communication is
now happening across these platforms. I would imagine most of it or most of it,
we,
we need to maybe stop drawing this arbitrary distinction that in person is a
completely different thing than over the internet. I mean,
maybe it's not increasingly, maybe it's more the same. Yeah.
Um, so I'm torn here, right?
On one side I say,
well it seems like they still allow him to have his freedom of expression
because he's still on YouTube. He still is able to upload his show on YouTube.
He will have to find other ways to make money. Sure.
So one part of me looks at it that way
and no one has a right to monetize on YouTube. Right, right,
right. So in a sense,
they haven't violated his first amendment rights because he's still able to
express himself. But then you go as a company,
they've a punitive decision to eliminate his ability or his radically reduce his
ability to make an income off of their platform. That seems like,
and I'm not supporting that, they did it,
but that seems more reasonable as a decision, right.
To say we're going to demonetize you. That seems more reasonable.
But the problem is there's no alternatives.
There's nothing remotely like YouTube too over there is an alternative to
YouTube for him to regain that same level of monetization. Yes.
Or for people that share his viewpoint and share his ideology and share his
positions. And there is no right-wing. YouTube is my point. And there's this,
I would challenge the idea that YouTube has is left wing.
I mean in terms of it's enforcing its policies. How so?
I mean they have just this, just this particular issue, but this isn't,
this isn't a a left wing. How is this a left wing enforcement?
I mean they think it is because Carlos maze is progressive and because the
argument that he was making his a very left wing progressive argument,
and this is what Crowder was going after,
he was going after the argument in the process of going after the argument,
he mocked his sexuality and his appearance.
I can assure you if it was focused merely on how much of a problem Antifa is,
this would not have happened. I mean, I think we both, Oh yeah, for sure. Yeah.
No, it's all about the mocking the guy's sexual orientation and looks.
That's where Carlos Mazda,
where a gay Republican and the exact same thing happened.
Do you think the outcome would have been different? Yes. Why?
I just don't think people be interested. Oh, well that's a dip boat. But,
so that gets to the real crux of it,
which is my real concern with this is YouTube only getting involved in even
publicly saying what they're doing about a channel, right?
When it becomes very public and it starts to have the possibility of impacting
their bottom line and brand, saying, yes, this is too hot and we're getting out.
Well, in that sense,
what Carlos did once it was revealed that YouTube was not going to take action
was very effective. Absolutely. I mean,
he started tweeting like crazy and people jumped on board.
He connected it to the LBGT movement and, and then it became this thing
[inaudible].